[Music]
my friend matt walsh and i have known
each other
for a long time at this point however
only recently have we moved to the same
town
spent a little more time together and so
now i want to test how well
we really know one another the game very
simple
each of us has a drink i'll let you
guess
whose is whose should i think it's
pretty obvious at this point uh
i've got the martini matt you've got the
beer
we're gonna read a prompt and then guess
how the other person would respond to
that prompt
i think i got it you think you got it
and then if you get it wrong you got a
drink
i mean i oh well that's fine that's fine
they were trying to get me to go
just straight whiskey for this game yeah
i thought it's three o'clock in the
afternoon right now so we're gonna be a
little bit more
three o'clock in the afternoon in
nashville yeah that's right what time is
it in dubai i don't know it's like in
the middle of the night over that's good
for you
you could do that i also feel i might be
at a bit of a disadvantage
because this is basically you know the
way i make a martini
is i pour cold gin into a glass while
looking at a bottle of vermouth on the
other side of the room
so this is a very boozy cocktail
well i'm at a disadvantage because i
would probably do poorly in this game
with anyone
because i don't know anything about
anyone
or pay attention to anyone because i'm a
narcissist and a sociopath so
that's the disadvantage i'm at cheers to
that sure we have a little sip just to
begin
okay what to being a narcissist and
associate being a narcissist and a
sociopath
so i don't have to chug the entire thing
for each wrong answer no no
that would make it interesting yes they
would now before we begin
this video is brought to you by ring
more from ring in just a moment
now without any further ado we get to
the first question
wearing glasses makes people appear
more intelligent oh is that yes so
what am i supposed to do so you've got
to guess you already have already
dropped
one sip of beer uh you have to guess how
i would respond
to that prompt and i will guess how you
would respond to that prompt
so for instance you are wearing glasses
so i think it's safe to say
you would agree with that prompt so i've
moved yours to the yes
okay now you've got to move do you agree
with that prompt
yes let's start over explain the whole
game again yes so basically these are
i'm going to say yeah so okay
i'm going to say you'll say no because
you're
because you could wear glasses but you
don't wear glasses most of the time you
know what
i think absolutely glasses do make you
look smarter
now do you know why i don't wear them
all the time why
because when i wear the glasses i look
exactly like rachel maddow
and this is no joke ben shapiro came up
to me one time he goes
michael you got to lose the glasses i
said what are you talking about he said
conservative
conservatives don't wear the glasses i
said yes what i say yeah i said why this
is actually
didn't even occur to me at this point
because you were still stuck in the car
in the middle of the woods yeah i
said no plenty of plenty of political
people on tv wear glasses
he said who i said you know rachel
maddow
uh lawrence o'donnell uh chris matthews
uh chris hayes on it was all the libs i
couldn't name a single conservative on
tv
you might be the one exception only the
libs wear glasses i never thought of it
only the lips because we can see so
clearly ourselves
well so that means i got it wrong we got
it wrong you have to drink i'll drink in
salt okay all right you have i gotta you
gotta reset over here do you have uh
contacts oh yeah i can barely see
everything's blurry but i just wanna
look like a conservative so i just throw
them out okay that's why i drive like a
maniac
uh ben shapiro likes me more
me as in me but it could be just to
clarify right because we're talking
about me no but it it's how would i re
hmm so are we talking about ourselves is
the me relating to both of us
you are going to answer whether i think
that
ben likes me more than you
why don't you just say i'm michael i
know well because then i'm going to
answer
if you think that ben likes you more
than me
i quit um i
yes so i'm gonna say but you you think
that ben likes you more than me
yes and then you gotta do i do i think
that ben is so established more than you
i think that you think that ben
likes me more than you yes
no that me me more than you okay so no
no
yeah yeah i think so i think that was
correct
i don't i don't even know what we
answered we i think we both got that one
right we both got that right
okay right i agree who wrote can you
write it a little clearer
for god's sakes
geez all right let's see maybe this one
will be clearer
leviticus 19 verse 28
was more of a chill suggestion making
tattoos completely
acceptable for christians today
acceptable is going to be doing a lot of
work here
so leviticus 1928 says no tattoos
well yeah now i
can't help but notice got a little ink
there
that's just that's henna that's fake i
do that i redo that every morning before
i come out yeah
nice henna cairo oh yeah the permanent
marker yeah the
the hindu artist or more likely some
like lib woman artist doing henna
tattoos she must be very confused every
morning
when you say i need the chiro on my arm
yeah well and see the
again the question is not framed
exactly correctly because my well i
don't want to give my answer until
you've guessed
okay so the so the question is
acceptable
is it are we talking about chill
suggestion yeah
is it unfair framing to begin with
yeah as far as i know god particularly
in the old testament does not generally
make
chill suggestions right neither chill
nor suggestion he would apply
to the old testament at any point so but
the question is today
do do those specific laws still hold
today
uh right and i i'm confident that you
would say
no that they don't hold
yes i suppose okay now yes
on the on the i think the substantive
read of the question
yes however the word acceptable right
it is it is my opinion that the only
people
who should have tattoos are
convicts and sailors
not body shame me first how dare you
it's you i will say you've got a kind of
burly
demeanor yeah you can pull and it's a
it's a
strange tattoo because it's it's an
ancient christian symbol
like it's oh is that what it is i don't
know if you know the uh i thought it was
japanese for water
i was going for i was going for rx like
prescription and yeah forgot that
you've got to go back i'm just a big fan
of uh yes okay so
we both got that right so i guess we
should drink
are those the rules by the way i know i
totally respect
um the view of uh hating tattoos yep
and i should be a guy who hates them so
it's very confusing for people yes
like um but in terms of the uh
the old testament argument i find it
absurd clearly those are not
those are ceremonial jewish laws that
don't and there is a difference between
moral laws ceremonial laws this right
this is
sometimes people get tripped up on this
but there are and especially tattoos
in that context would have been pagan
symbolism
right but also if you get the little
like the japanese from water you know
like the 20 year old white girls do
that that is immoral that is a damnable
offense
i will agree through that yes okay okay
i would rather be stuck in an elevator
with a bleeding heart burning bro
communist than a libertarian who thinks
we can all get along if people just
let you do you okay now you is your
answer to this
uh rather be stuck with the burning bro
than a libertarian
all right i'm just going to go for it
uh i'm going to say yes you would rather
be stuck
with the bernie bro oh i misunderstood
the question
you would rather be yesterday okay yeah
yeah
yes i think yes you would rather be
stuck with the bernie bro than the
libertarian
and i certainly would rather be stuck at
the bernie we're on the same page yes
there's no question
uh libertarians probably annoy me more
than any other humans on earth at this
point in my
yes it is in college we used to sing a
song
it's not a joke we'd say god wrought you
libertarians you fill me with dismay
your anarchistic tendencies you're
i forget i was usually even a little
more uh
lubricated when i was singing it in
college but the point is yeah
libertarianism
super lame yeah okay agreed
let's see uh so now i'm uh generally
speaking
america should not get involved with
conflicts
in taiwan or israel so we've got to
reset
uh what you're going to answer on this
america generally speaking america
should not get involved with conflicts
in taiwan or
israel
i think you're going to say i'm going to
give you a yes
yeah i think that's about right yeah
because the generally speaking here is
the key right exactly
right i think there when it is in
america's interest and there can be
times when it's in america's interest to
push back china or to push back certain
arab states
then we certainly should but general as
an ongoing matter of constantly managing
these places
uh probably not probably that would be
an interesting alliance generally in
favor of allowing countries to handle
their own
affairs yeah so yeah we keep getting
them right but we're just still drinking
so i guess
that's fine cool sounds like we're
winning
all right um
there are a lot of questions too yeah uh
matthew mcconaughey
is more likely to win a governor race in
texas than caitlyn jenner
in california so it's more likely not
who would you rather she win
more likely yeah okay i'll answer
yeah i'm assume that you'd say yes to
that
totally yeah i mean i know that right
now it's fashionable
for conservatives to say that you know
democrats are the real transphobes or
whatever
but uh it i don't caitlin's not going to
win right
i don't think so he is uh polling at
like
two percent wow he's pulling it so repub
conservatives are
buying in to the left basically giving
up on reality
for the sake of this trans candidate
who's not even going to win
wait so i thought when you said he i
assumed you were referring to matthew
oh yeah sorry justin you were calling
bruce jenner
the guy in the wheaties box that he
caitlyn jenner
i'll respect the name you know i'm i
i've long respected the name i'm
getting to the point where i i don't
know that i will beco
here's why yeah you can change your name
whatever prince can become a symbol
right and he's the artist
but caitlyn is a woman's name
i don't think that a dude should go by
caitlyn
i agree with you there yeah but a name
actually is a social construct
so like that that is the social it's
something we come up with just a
it's it is a symbol to represent a
person that's right and it's an
arbitrary symbol so it could be anything
um maybe it's as long as you've changed
if you change it legally
then that's your name i don't yeah i
don't know i think i might be more of a
theocratic fascist than you are in this
case now i got to recalibrate my
position yes because
here's what i think that name i have to
scramble to get to the right to the
right of you
on this no one gets names it should be
right yes it's illegal to have a name
because i
i think it's a symbol right they're
symbols but you get a name
at birth right it's your christian name
we say yeah i don't think you should be
able to really to change it and also by
the
way
if we can call men caitlyn then johnny
cash's song a boy named sue
is no law it was never funny but it's no
longer even ostensibly we have destroyed
that
song yeah uh yeah i don't really
i don't agree with what you're saying
but i don't want to be in the position
of arguing
the liberal side of it right so i'm just
going to move on from that
fair enough am i up now mm-hmm yeah okay
i have confidence that the 2022 midterms
will bring a relative
red wave
a relative red wave what the hell what
is that
it took me a second for that to sink in
redundant a relative red wave uh
okay else maybe you'll be more
optimistic on this one
drink okay i'm firmly
in the no category i'm not saying no
it won't happen i'm saying i'm not
confident and i'm not confident
because democrats rewrote all the
election laws and gave themselves a lot
of advantages
i wish i could be confident but i'm not
yeah my
my lack of confidence is more is the
general pessimism
to life but and and to the republicans
uh so
you know they are very good at clutching
defeat from the jaws of victory
yeah they're expert at that and we need
to know a little bit more about what a
red wave would even mean but yeah i
think they'll pick up some
some yeah but they sort of have to right
if they didn't pick up some seats
something would have gone seriously
wrong but maybe something that yeah
all right of course i know what you're
saying this all parties involved in the
production distribution of pornography
should be arrested and held criminally
liable
yeah so it's just it's like cool
strength to that yeah straight to that
um it's my criminal justice reform by
the way yeah
that's my first step act first step to
recovering a sense of true liberty yeah
i i actually i'm a little bit of
optimism there it it
it seems to me that there's a growing
sense
on the right yeah to treat pornography
in this way because
five six years ago even when this when
this first subject really came up it was
like a few years ago we were talking
about it
and the the backlash from the right was
intense just from like the boomer
libertarian right yeah they were like
what yeah you know thomas jefferson
loved porn yeah
george washington had a subscription to
only fans yeah this is what our founders
envisioned
this is a blessing of liberty yeah right
uh but it seems to be especially among
younger conservatives
it seems to be a little bit of a shift
there so totally well you know the irony
is
all the kind of boomer con you know
libertarian types they'll say like guys
come
what you're not gonna look at porn all
the time and you know i bet a lot of
those zoomers those like 18 year old
conservatives who are super anti-porn
i bet they've looked at porn hypocrites
it's like uh yeah i bet they have i bet
they realize how horrible it is
and that's why they're so opposed to it
they've grown up a lot of these kids
grow they were exposed to when they're
like seven yes and uh and they just see
how empty and
and gross and disgusting it is so yeah
yeah that's good i had something to
celebrate uh
that's it this is me okay vegans should
not be allowed to vote
vegan should not be allowed to vote
should not be allowed to vote
um i'm going to assume that you would
probably say no to that
vegans should not be allowed to vote
you know i i'm gonna say that you're
gonna be pretty moderate here
kind of a more of a liberal and that's a
risky move i'm gonna
and you're gonna say that maybe the
vegans should be allowed to vote
well okay there's a little bit of a
nuance here because
i believe strongly in greatly reducing
the number of people who can legally
vote of course
greatly reducing it yes um through any
number of
means yes and i think that through the
means that i have in mind
most vegans will be ruled out yes i
agree
i'm with you but it probably wouldn't be
determined based on their veganism so
yes
this is the issue the venn diagram of
people who should be disqualified from
voting
and vegans it's it's like right yeah
it's almost
exactly a circle but i don't think it's
totally yeah
synonymous yeah so we can take care of
them without having to directly
yes target them because that would raise
constitutional issues because i think
just
in the same place that you had a
constitutional right to look at weird
porn and stuff
do you have the constitutional guarantee
that vegans can vote yeah in the same
panel exactly
yeah the crusades
were unprovoked aggression towards the
peaceful muslim world well
that's just okay oh yeah okay i almost
put you towards you
it's scary yeah there it is i mean
that's that's the funniest prompt that
we've had yet
not much to talk about there defeating
the saracens and retaking the holy land
they usual i'm going to run out by the
way do we get more
while we wait for our drinks to be
poured i need to tell you
how important it is to protect your home
and you can protect your home with
ring it makes it so easy this is very
important for me these days
because i've got cute little june my
newborn baby i've got
sweet little alisa my beautiful wife and
i want to be able to know that they're
safe whether i'm at home whether i'm at
the office whether i'm on the other side
of the world
i can see and speak to whoever is at my
door using my ring app
so i'm not saying it's going to be some
burglar or something but what if it's
walsh i don't want some sketchy guy like
matt walsh
necessarily just being on my doorstep
and no one knows that it's him
maybe for you who knows maybe it's your
in-laws or coming to town
you find this out on the app you stay
perfectly still nobody
makes a breath nobody moves a muscle
with ring you can secure every inch of
your house start protecting
your home today with ring alarm how you
do it's very
easy you go to ring.com knowles can wlas
to get your ring alarm security kit
today
you can build the system that's right
for your home have it up and running in
minutes so easy to install even i can do
it
ring.com that is ring.com
knowles back to the questions
vaccine passports seem more like a
prophecy from revelation
than a public health concern or benefit
uh yeah i'm assuming you say yes or no
yeah that's not it that's not a tricky
one i find
um i think it's a little strong i mean
prophecy from revelation i don't know if
i'd put it that way i'm not saying they
seem
like a prophecy but i'm more like more
like yeah yeah i'll go with that
you know the thing is i don't i don't
think we're living in the end times you
know i don't ever they're always worried
about this is the mark of the beast or
that's the mark of the beast
but you know someone's going to be
living in the end times right i mean
it's yeah it's got to be someone but
like i don't think it's me well i don't
think i am but
you could think of plenty of periods
through history where they would have
had a better case
black yes you know um things like that
but
but uh yeah i mean the vaccine passport
i'm very much against
as far as whether people get a vaccine
you don't care that's my thing i don't i
don't get it if you want or don't if you
don't yeah
that's best yeah i'm not i'm not
hardcore enough to say like definitely
don't get it
but i but i am prudential enough to
think like hey
if you think if if you make a risk
calculation and you say that the risk
is is better for me to get the vaccine
then just do it you know if you're in an
at-risk group or something
okay cool but if you're a healthy 28
year old or something and
and you you just think well i i face
statistically like
no risk from this virus yeah then i
don't
the the creepy kind of backs or mask or
vote or die or whatever that i just
think it's so
creepy it makes me less likely to want
to do it every time you say it
yeah that's right let people make their
own decisions that's uh
here we go aliens more than likely exist
this does not include illegal or
naturalized aliens michael knowles
that's on the card
um guatemalans definitely exist
yeah okay so i think you're gonna say no
on that i think you're gonna say yes
you're absolutely right you're right
you're totally right i don't if you
asked me today put
50 000 on do aliens exist or not i'd say
they do not but that determination on
your part
is almost entirely has a theological
respect part of it is
i i always i never got into aliens even
when i was an atheist i was like i mean
i don't really think there's aliens
right and it's like because
they'd always be like but the universe
is big and i was like well
okay whatever it's like it's big and
sterile most mostly like why don't but
it's just so it
i know you don't find the universe's big
argument to be compelling i think it is
because of
just how we're talking about 100 billion
galaxies or more in the observable
universe yeah
100 billion galaxies 100 billion stars
in each galaxy give or take
yeah um you know let's say five or six
planets on average around each
each star yeah okay how many planets
does that make
yeah no i mean they're let's say there's
like a gazillion planets i just
the the fact that there's a bunch of
rocks does not to me imply
that there's a life on any of them well
but if you were to
okay because we don't know the or we
don't know anything about the origin of
life as a
sort of scientific matter certainly if
you were to take religion completely out
of it which you can't
but if you were yeah then you're looking
at it as a matter of pure statistics
yeah what's the statistical likelihood
of there being life on other planets but
i think
in order to do the statistical analysis
you've got to
know how you go from not life to life
right because that's the
it i have no doubt that if there's some
kind of life that you could get some
kind of other life
i'm kind of there i think that's but if
we if we have
truly no scientific understanding of how
of how
life starts then and we there are some
theories on it but there's no
good evidence for them then even let's
say there's a
million places in resilient places
what what do the statistics matter if we
don't know that that fundamental process
well that's what i'm saying if you take
if if if you were to take religion out
of it you're saying even as an atheist
you have this view
so then it's a matter of i guess
a planet is like a chemistry set and a
bunch of chemicals are being mixed
randomly and then that's how you start
life that's what that's the hypothesis i
guess
right well that's if there's no you know
if you take religion out of it that's
what it has to be it has to be something
like that so then so then it's just a
matter of if you have enough those
chemistry sets going
at the same time it's just likely you
know a certain number of them are going
to are going to land
are going to you know the die is going
to be cast this is very interesting so
what you're saying is
absent the existence of god right absent
the existence of god if which i don't
it's like
to me everything that follows from that
is just like gobbledygook because
how do you true it's like this is the
sustaining essence of the universe
but so absent the existence of god the
only way that life could develop has to
be
from non-life in some kind of primordial
soup
without god right yeah so therefore
because that's obviously just nonsense
because that like because that
we just don't have any evidence that
that happened therefore god exists
that's like another argument for god
right i would agree with you yeah but
i'm talking about so there's that part
of it
and then okay but let's get back into
reality we bring god back into the
equation yeah
uh that makes it a little more
interesting but i think it actually
makes the case for
intelligent life on other planets more
compelling because now we're talking
about
um whereas without god those all these
planets exist for really no purpose
they're just they just happen to be
there including our own
yeah uh now all these planets have
there's a reason all those planets are
there god intentionally created every
single one of them
so if there are gazillion planets right
there are gazillion planets in the
universe
uh this god individually made every
single one of them for a reason
yeah and um so it just becomes harder
for me to understand
now this c.s lewis was was open to
aliens
right so there are plenty of prominent
christians who are open to aliens
however does this not raise the problem
of
monogenism monogenism the fancy term for
the idea that we
all descend from a common ancestor and
this is very important to make sense of
original sin broken human nature
human solidarity human dignity all the
way down to why racism is bad right it's
racism is bad because we're all part of
the same family you know the same line
if we aren't then it raises issues of
even what a human being
is so does that do the aliens not raise
a problem
adam and eve at all yeah and now we're
drinking we're talking about this i'm
worried
i'm going to venture into heresy but uh
so i'm trying i will drink more yeah
yeah but i think that uh uh i like c.s
lewis's thoughts on this
and i don't know exactly how this works
with salvation history but
first of all the fact that i can't
figure out how to work it within
the theological framework that i
understand doesn't that is definitive
that it's not possible right
right exactly but it's not actually
definitive so that's the point but but
also uh
maybe this is why the universe is so
vast there's so much space in between
all these different planets because
god does not actually want um
these different races of intelligent
beings intermingling because they're at
different places and they're
it would seem to me that assuming that
the trinity is true sort of the central
history of christianity
then you have the second person of the
blessed trinity is christ as the logos
of the universe
incarnate dies once on the cross to
redeem mankind and
and redeem the fallen world okay so it
would seem difficult for me
to understand how there's another sort
of salvation on some other planet with
with
with the second person of the trinity
who dies once for all
so that would seem very hard so then it
would seem to imply that the the other
creatures are not fallen
that that's possible so that could be
possible that yeah
c.s lewis you know speculated about that
yeah but
and that goes back to why our nearest
solar system
is four light years away which is 25
trillion miles so
and that's our next door neighbor that's
like a hop skip and a jump away and
galactic term so
and that that's close yeah so why is
there so much in
space in between each maybe it's because
of this problem of
you can't have a you can't have a fallen
race interacting with a non-fallen race
because the interesting thing there then
is that like the fallen race
now becomes sort of like the snake in
the garden of eden
yeah playing that role and um right
right
so maybe that's the reason why i mean
it's all speculation but
what fermi just comes down to the
universe is very big there's lots of
planets in it they serve some sort of
purpose
and we are a bunch of snakes and we are
a bunch of snakes
at least know a bunch of snakes here and
especially in politics yeah yeah okay
that's good
uh am i up you're on i think so i don't
know we've been with
oh man i know the names of
more than half of the people who work
here so now
we're answering so definitely for you
that's like not even a question
um of more than half i don't know we
hire like 27 people an
hour here yeah it's hard to keep i'm
going to say for you
also well i wouldn't put it past you to
know everyone's name in this whole damn
building but i'm gonna say no
you know you know what you know what the
trick is here
because i think i actually don't know
the answer to this because we seriously
we hire however
like a dozen people a day but the real
trick is
like oh hey buddy you know hey
pal yeah nicely and you think i don't
it's like is it
is it like it matt is it
is his name matt or mickey or in
fairness
i don't think i don't think any
individual person in this building knows
the name of
because we're hiring so many people so
that's true yeah yeah except for the
good people who actually care about
their co-workers
well unlike the bad fallen snakes such
as
us exactly okay we should drink for that
yeah it's also frankly i don't even
think our boss bill shapiro knows
whatever his name is something like that
um
bill gates isn't jeffrey epstein
why is there apostrophe there was a
person who wrote these questions drunk
already
you guys were trying the journey right
they were tipping into the bootles
bill gates and jeffrey epstein just
happen to have been really good friends
no funny business um that's i'm gonna
get that's obviously a no
pretty as persuasive as that sounds no
yeah no i i like the claim that uh they
were
that bill gates was consulting jeffrey
epstein on
for marriage advice because if if you're
having problem problems in your marriage
of course you're going to consult
an international sex international sex
trafficker pedophile who's never been
married
he's the guy that you're gonna hey what
do you think do you think melinda and i
are gonna work out
i don't know all right when
people recognize me in public it
genuinely warms my heart
i've never been recognized in public so
no yes you have i'm kidding yes um
uh you've been recognized now the only
question is
can matt walsh's heart be warmed
yeah i'm gonna say for you the answer is
yes it absolutely is for me
for you you know i'm gonna say yes
it does i was hoping i could surprise
you if you put it on no no it but
beneath that gruff
burly bearded exterior there is
a very sweet warm cauldron of sympathy
and humanity i don't know if i go that
far but
it almost warms my heart but then it
because i'm catholic it
verges quickly into guilt and shame
because then i start thinking
like why does this person care like yeah
i'm such an insignificant
why a piece of dirt of a person just
yeah right so
but there's a little bit of a warming of
a heart that happens yeah
and then when you before congratulate
yourself the stimulated blood
flow literally warms your heart that's
true yeah that's true
oh no it's your is it your turn is it
mine
okay on a scale of one to ten
the current pope is not super great
this is where i go back to my theory
that the person who wrote the questions
was drunk because i'm not sure what
not not super great but the one to ten
oh yeah this is why doing a scale of one
to ten
if the statement is the current pope is
not super great
yeah that's uh well i guess there's one
one name we don't need to learn around
these parts probably not going to be
here very long
yeah uh okay so the pope is not
super great is the prompt yeah well i
it's not wait it's not super great yes
so you're saying you're saying i would
agree with the statement the pope is not
super great
and i'm saying you would disagree with
the statement the pope is not super
great
so you're saying this i'm going to say
that you say that the pope
is super great and you're saying that i
don't think the pope is super great yes
but now that you put my drink over there
i'm rethinking my decision but i've
already made it
he's the pontifex maximus oh he's
literally super right yes yeah hold on a
second
yeah but we're talking about i assume
we're talking about the
the personality the the actual
individual well this is the the issue of
course yes
i would be i would never
denigrate the holy father and paul
couldn't do it
now when one says things that are
unfortunate when one says things that
raise a lot of confusion
when one says things that are outright
heresy in some cases
this is very confusing and this would
raise
filial questions and dubia and doubts
but i would never say look i'm not some
lib who thinks that i can just start
mouthing off about the pope
and start start accusing people outright
of saying things that are
sometimes it seems kind of heretical you
know
i mean i would argue that saying
heretical things is not super great yeah
no that's
not a super great thing to do no i super
i totally agree with that yeah okay
i think we both answered wrong i think
we yeah and but maybe we both answer
right
at the same time yes and no
okay now now
[Music]
on a scale of a to 17 no that's not what
it
is
radical islam is still more dangerous
than
radical leftism oh i'm
the miracle's almost i'm pretty sure
you're gonna say no
radical islam is still more dangerous
than radical
leftism i'm i'm gonna say no for you as
well
yeah i'm for me that's an easy one yeah
personally
um my only problem with the question is
the still because i don't think that it
ever was that it ever
yeah well it's just because leftism has
only been a real political
problem in the last few hundred years uh
okay whereas islam has been a political
problem for like 1500 years
yeah um of course you have to think
about what do we mean by danger
are we talking about a physical danger
well then that might that might sway it
slightly but
it's it's tricky in the sense that
leftism is just an
inversion of christianity it comes out
of this christian civilization
and it just inverts everything so in a
way you know
it's the same way that it's easier to
talk to the arden atheist
than it is to the agnostic because the
arden atheist is really thinking about
these issues
so you know the radical leftist maybe
you can kind of get them but the
argument is even truer for islam islam
it derives out of a christian heresy and
this is not even really disputed by
muslims right that
that muhammad meets a heretical
christian monk and then goes on and
develops this islamic religion but i
think if i'm talking to some
kook you know atheist or even worse some
decadent just agnostic
lib it's very we don't
we're not even talking about the same
thing whereas if i'm talking to some
radical is islamic person yeah
that guy is thinking about the same
things i'm thinking about we're actually
speaking kind of
i don't speak arabic but we're speaking
the same language the question is just
about the answers to those questions so
yeah i mean i think that's certainly
right
yeah i guess i would look at it like
this i don't i don't know that there's
any
person who has ever not made it to
heaven
or any christian who's ever been been
been
not made into heaven because of islam
islam can can persecute and kill them
but i mean at the end of the day that's
actually
expedites their their trip whereas with
leftism i think that the attack is much
more
internal and uh i think it has a very
far different effect
so that is really good you very rarely
hear
of christians converting to islam
right but you you do hear of christians
converting to leftists well
in this country millions millions and
millions much of the country that's a
very that's a very good point
yeah right i make those on occasion yeah
every once in a while really okay
after a couple beers
so you're up all right um
having facial hair covers insecurities
more effectively than the lack of facial
hair insect impotence
wait a second we gotta get them
phrases having facial hair covers
insecurities more effectively
than the lack of facial hair hints at
impotence
it it let me see i got it i can't
yeah so that having facial hair
covers insecurities more effectively
more if or more did a literate person
write these questions or
i i don't know more if so i said let me
rephrase this to make it even
semi plausible to interpret
facial hair having facial hair
uh is is aimed more
at covering insecurities
then the lack of facial hair suggests or
implies
impotence that doesn't clarify it for me
but yeah okay
um okay i i don't want to give my i'll
just say that you're going to say uh
yes yeah i get i mean i'm not a you know
i have a kid i have a baby
yeah so i'm going to say that you're
going to say
say that you're going to say no you're
correct because i just reject the entire
premise of the question
you're just going to say no to the
question i say no to the question to the
whole premise
having a beer is not about it's covering
insecure what does that even mean that's
it also i mean that there there is no
meaning to that prompt
right because it doesn't obey sort of
basic rules of grammar
right so i just rejected a principle and
you know man a guy with a beard probably
doesn't give a damn about grammar rules
you know that guy is going to go chop
down trees and whatever well
yeah um here's what i hate about so many
things but
that facial hair has become like i'm
accused of being a hipster all the time
for having facial hair yeah yeah oh yeah
like you're making a statement it's like
this is
since time immemorial men have grown
beards i'm not trying to say anything
yeah it's just being a man i know i i
started to grow over christmas i would
say you know i'm gonna grow a beard
everyone's got a beard
right drew's got a beard jeremy's got a
beard matt's got a beer i'll grow a
beard
i don't know if i would call theirs
beards but yeah it's not quite
so i start growing it's you know it's
whatever i'm looking a little scraggly
but it's
and it's a little bit on the a little on
the patchy sort of
but i can grow a mustache in about four
hours that is the one
it takes me 10 years to grow a beard i
can grow a mustache in a blink of an eye
but some guys are not meant for
mustaches and i give a lot of
talks at schools and if i grow out this
mustache
i i will not be permitted within 300
yards of the school i i re i just
reject that i think that you should do
it i'm very pro mustache okay
uh i think it's a great look and
mustaches are back as far as i know all
right i mean i love them i love a good
mustache
yeah and you could probably get the
whole cause you got to go the whole oh
yeah i do
i can get it mine's like a slug mine
looks like a disgusting slug on my
little
that's what it's called crumb catcher
that's what it needs to be yeah well
soup strainer is what it is
how would your how would your wife feel
about it she would come around to it
i think given this time scale of
eternity
maybe yeah if you give her no choice i
mean
yeah all right the masks did
nothing to help the public at large and
were merely a political tool to frighten
voters into believing a new
administration was
needed now hold on due to youtube rules
make your guess but do not verbally
confirm if the other person
guessed correctly give only an ambiguous
confirmation so i'll read that prompt
again knowing that rule
the masks did
nothing to help the public at large
and they were merely a political tool to
frighten
voters into believing that a new
administration
was needed so now we have to guess how
the other person would answer that's
very interesting theoretical
[Music]
prompt
well you're up yeah
um race hustlers who intentionally
mislead and stir up riots should be held
criminally responsible if violence
breaks out yeah
clearly yeah to their uh future
prosecution
well that's never going to happen for
sure
it's like next year in jerusalem right
it's like waiting for elijah yep
okay we should go back to spreading our
original american ideals to other
countries
and involving ourselves in their
business if they are not preserving
freedom and democracy
i guess i kind of tipped my hand on that
one yeah
yeah no no i have zero interest
i don't have any interest in spreading
democracy here so
what i want democracy oh yeah i don't
even want it here it's also the idea of
democracy you know or the idea of
freedom i don't
i don't like those things floating
around in outer space yeah
i like the real enacted
and fleshed lived experience of those
things i love the american tradition of
freedom oh yeah i'll get into that
the american government and system yeah
traditional
i'll get into that but like it's like
that meme you know it's like
mud democracy or like my freedom no i
don't want that in it i don't want to
floating in the abstract
but also stuff also the idea that
democracy is this universally
yeah great thing that that works for
everyone in every culture
everywhere in the world throughout time
in history is absurd obviously
it's also the idea that the cycle of
regimes is not
a fact of the political world and the
idea that democracy is the only in any
case legitimate form of government does
raise this
observation which is the kingdom of god
not a democracy so what what do you
think is the most ideal form of
government well i do i'm not like
anti-republic i'm not i'm i'm definitely
i'm not one of these totally reactionary
anti-republic people
but i think they're perfectly legitimate
monarchies and i think there's quite a
lot
about a monarchy certainly a
constitutional monarchy that
gives itself credit and by the way i
don't know if you've noticed this
but you know the libs always talk about
our democracy
especially these days it's always the
libs and then the kind of squishy
republicans they say are this is a
threat to
our democracy and i think it was angelo
cotavilla at the claremont institute
who pointed out that every time these
guys refer to
our democracy they're they are without
fail referring to their oligarchy
it's always the people who are the most
sort of elite anti-democratic people in
the world
yeah yeah that's true that's the irony
um i've spent more time hanging out with
my producer than you have with yours
now we're getting personal yeah so i'm
going to assume
i'm going to assume you've not hung out
with your producer
oh i can't answer the question until you
can't yes so i'm going to say
but it's like oh so again we have the
problem of the eye
so the i refers to the person who is
answering
no no i'm sorry it doesn't it refers to
the opposite i'm i'm trying to answer if
you
would say i've hung out with my producer
more than you michael have hung out with
yours
wait okay i think what no yes
yeah i think that's fair because i don't
i gotta tell you know ever since
ever since we moved here i had this
little kid
so my social life went from like cool
guy
hitting hitting the club every night to
just
suburban dad taking the grill pill
outside you know hanging out at home
but i have hung out with my producer
we've traveled we've done these things
i'm gonna guess you have not um
i have but only recently because
i've only recently been in the office
so but i think you probably have more
because i've got a longer time scale
right yeah
that's fair okay all right probably
still drink
do you need a top off do i need a top
off uh i think i'm
good so now it's my my my go
reading the church of cowards left me
speechless
sure yeah why not let's just go with it
that's great
a little book plug from speechless
um let's go to one zip line when does
that uh when does that come out
comes out june 22nd it's available now
for pre-order you can get it on amazon
you can get it premiere collectibles for
a signed first edition copy you can text
some number that i totally forget
but whatever you do make sure you get it
the act of going fishing is not really a
thing
it's merely a ploy to leave the house
and finally get some peace and quiet
hmm i haven't i have a definite opinion
for myself about this but i'm going to
say
that you would say you're saying don't
really say yes
yeah you're correct i'm very much for me
the act of going fishing is all about
fishing yeah
i'm in i'm in campus well i've just
recently i
i i'd occasionally gone fishing as a kid
i
recently went uh fly fishing in utah
yeah
it's it's a transcendent experience it
is it really is
it's great i i did not know that i don't
it's weird because you if you said to
someone hey
you're going to put on boots you know
sort of silly boots
and stand in in cold water just stand
for like
five hours and that's going to be very
beautiful and fun you would not
anticipate that to be true what i like
about fishing
um i've been an avid angler as we call
ourselves in the business
yeah for several years now but what i
like about fishing is that
some people say that oh yeah it's an
excuse to get out of the house or
drinking or whatever
and that's fine too uh but really for me
it's
or or you know you can think about it's
a time to think about things and
no but when i'm fishing i'm just
thinking about fishing that's all i'm
thinking about
i'm i'm and that's what i like about it
you're focused on this one
skill this one simple act you got to
find the fish you got to catch them
and uh i think in that way it's sort of
liberating this
winston churchill said this about
painting he said you got to take up
painting because it's the only way to
get your mind on something else he said
you can't
if you want your mind to relax you can't
just do nothing because then you just
think about all your stresses
and you can't read because it's using
the same muscles that use all the time
but if you paint it's using different
muscles and you're so focused then
you'll
and i think the same thing is true about
fishing you're just you're just
casting it out there you're watching
very closely you're trying to feel
whatever you show
five hours goes by it's like two seconds
yeah
that's how i feel about it and you know
you know what what i also have in common
with fish drinking absolutely
i think i is i want to keep a track i
think i won this did i win
we can defer to the let's say i'm trying
to see what i'm hearing from the judges
i think i won you don't have an earpiece
in but okay
i'll go with that thanks for joining us
we'll see you next time on this uh this
game i frankly in a sense i think we all
won
[Music]
[Music]
agreed